You know, there's
this idea floating
around which I totally buy.
And it's this notion that
we are already cyborgs.
People are so
dystopian when they
think about the
future of technology.
But what they fail to realize is
that we have been in a feedback
loop, in a
self-amplifying feedback
loop with our technology
since the origin of language
and stone tools, for Chrissakes.
We use our
technologies to extend
the boundaries of what we are.
Our tools are our exoskeletons.
They are scaffoldings extending
our thought, reach, and vision,
as Andy Clark says.
There's a book by Andy Clark
called Natural Born Cyborgs.
And him and David Chalmers,
they coined the extended mind
thesis, which is this idea
that we're literally extending
the boundaries of the human
mind with these technologies.
Our Smartphones are
extensions of our cognition.
They are examples of
distributed intelligence.
iPhone, therefore I am.
I mean, literally, this
idea that our second skin
is our technology.
It's our turtle shell.
It's our exoskeleton.
It sort of blurs the boundary
of saying that there's nature
and then there's technology.
And that in fact, it's
all on a continuum.
And we, just smack in the
middle between the born
and the made, as
Kevin Kelly says.
But even Nietzsche used to say,
man is a bridge and not an end.
We are a means towards
self-extension.
Our technology has
become part of our skin.
We must get over
our skin bag bias,
the biological skin bag
is just one membrane.
Our cells have membranes, too.
But our body's
still a part of us,
and our tools are a part of us.
We transcend membranes.
We extend ourselves.
That's what we do.
We are already cyborgs.